- [Narrator] Hey hotties, let's talk
about Bitcoin.
- Bitcoin's almost 65,000.
- And make Bitcoin unofficial currency.
- Last time we talked about crypto
it kind of seemed like the good
times would just never end.
(cork popping)
- [Reporter] Cryptocurrency
is going mainstream.
- [Matt Damon] Fortune favors the brave.
- [Reporter] Crypto.com overnight.
- And then they did.
- It's been a brutal week
for crypto investors.
Founder and CEO Sam
Bankman-Fried has announced
his official resignation.
(man screaming)
- Not only did all these
graphs go down, but one
of the largest crypto platforms
went bust when we discovered
that the founder was using
tons of investors money
to fund his other company
and not telling anyone.
Totally not okay.
- [Newscaster] Crypto exchange FTX files
for Chapter 11 bankruptcy today.
- [Reporter] It's safe to say
there were red flags all over the play.
- As of last week it
was worth $32 billion.
- Surely it had to be some sort of scam.
- This is why you're
seeing this guy's face all
over the news lately.
He literally lost like
over $10 billion overnight.
- So now I feel a bit vindicated.
- While all of this
turmoil has been going down
crypto actually had a huge win lately.
Something that no one's
really talking about.
- [Reporter] Waiting for the Merge.
- [Announcer] The Merge
- [Commentator] The Merge
merge.
- They really solved one
of their biggest problems.
So that's what I wanna focus on today.
So what happened?
And is it enough to save the cryptoverse?
(hands clapping)
Let's do this.
- [Reporter] The merge is
perhaps the most important update
in Ethereum's history.
- Can you explain it to everyone?
- This is the biggest
development in the crypto space.
- [Announcer] Crypto's most
ambitious change to date.
- Hey, before we go on,
I need to pay my bills
and thank today's sponsor.
Cut now to that, please.
Boy, do we have something
good in store today.
I'm not gonna spoil it
but just say it took an
entire day to film this video.
Before we get into it, I
wanna think today's sponsor
which is a service that
we're actually using
to make this video, kind of meta.
Thank you, Storyblocks,
for supporting this video.
Check this out, crypto farm.
With Storyblocks, you pay one set price
and then you get unlimited
access to all of this stuff.
There's over a million
assets on this website
and you can download as much as you want.
Like as much as you want.
What I like to do is just
download a bunch of this stuff,
test it out in my edit.
The stuff I use, I use.
The stuff I don't use,
I'm not charged for.
All right, maybe I don't want footage.
Maybe I want templates.
Like if you're not an animator,
but you kind of wanna be an animator,
literally you can just download
an after effects template
and you're an animator.
Yeah, I know how to animate
but I secretly use templates all the time.
It cuts down on hours of work.
And they just made a plugin for Premier.
So you could literally just
have Storyblocks inside
of your video editor.
You're just pulling stuff.
You're not like going and
downloading and moving the file.
It's all in Premiere.
I've been using Storyblocks
for literally a decade.
Well before I was a YouTuber
or before they came to sponsor a video
because it's seriously the
best place to find a bunch
of really good stuff for very cheap.
You pay one set price
either annual or monthly.
That's it.
There's no hidden fees,
there's no extra thing
and it's a very small
price to pay to take back
your creative control
and to have like access
to all of of this good stuff.
So thank you Storyblocks
for supporting this video,
for supporting my channel.
There's a link in my description.
It's storyblocks.com/johnnyharris.
Clicking that link, unsurprisingly,
helps support this channel
but it also allows you to go learn more
about how to get in on
this amazing service.
Thank you, again, Storyblocks.
All right, let's get
into this crypto video.
We've got a lot to cover.
Okay, so before we get into
what changed in the crypto verse
which is a very big deal,
let's do a little refresher
for those who need it.
This time with a little bit of a spin.
Hold on a second.
(percussion music)
Welcome to crypto 102.
This is really (beep) stupid.
Why am I doing this?
Every time I have to
explain the blockchain
to people I have to do
some gimmick to be like,
"I'm gonna teach you the blockchain
"using the simplest version."
No, I'm done.
I'm not doing it, (beep) the blockchain.
Let's do this.
If you wanna understand
why internet money is
making the ocean rise
all you really have to understand is this.
This is a crypto mining farm.
It is a warehouse full
of specialized computers that have one job
and one job only, solving math problems.
(indistinct)
These things are all over the world.
Hell, I was in a Swiss
bunker a couple weeks ago
and the guy I was interviewing
had one of these things.
- I am mining Bitcoin at the same time.
- [Johnny] Yeah, yeah.
- Is this just another way for me
to slip Switzerland into a video
that's completely unrelated?
It totally is.
Any chance I have, I will
mention my favorite country.
Anyway, these machines all
over the world are sitting here racing
against each other to solve a
complicated math puzzle first.
And if you're the lucky
computer that solves one
of these complicated
puzzles, you win the race.
And that allows you to
verify what's called a block
which is just a little box of data.
On the Bitcoin blockchain, for example,
this block is only one megabyte of data.
It's just big enough to hold
like 2000 transactions
that people have made
with their cryptocurrency.
As you publicly verify
this block of transactions
it gets added to a long chain
of a bunch of other blocks
that have been verified
by the same math puzzle race process
and they sort of get strung together
into a publicly available,
totally verified chain
of transactions verified
by fancy computers
that do a bunch of math.
It is called a blockchain.
Wait, no, I'm not here to
explain the blockchain.
I'm supposed to be explaining this.
So why would a bunch of people
around the world pay a lot
of money to make these big warehouses
so that they can verify a math puzzle?
Because if you're the
one who owns the computer
that successfully solves the math puzzle
and verifies the block of
transactions, you get rewarded.
In the case of Bitcoin right
now, you'd get 6.25 bitcoins.
Which is like, I don't know,
nothing more than $125,000.
(cash register ringing)
So yeah, there's a huge
incentive for people
to build these things and
to mine all day for Bitcoin.
Anyway, this race to
complete math problems uses
up a lot of processing
power, a lot of energy.
It takes a whole lot of work
for your computer to run
through all of these
computations trying to figure
out what the answer is
and that's why this method
is called Proof of Work.
Every computer that
verifies the transactions
on the blockchain has to do a lot of work.
This is all well and cute
until you think through
all the energy that goes
into building these
machines, and then you think
of the electricity it takes
to run them day and night
and then you remember that
they get really hot when
they're running all the time
doing these computations.
So you need to cool
them down with AC units.
- Let's all cool down.
- And then remember that
most of the electricity
we use today comes from
burning hydrocarbons
which releases a nice thick blanket of CO2
into the atmosphere that warms the planet
and contributes to the
ongoing global warming crisis.
(bomb exploding)
So yeah, that's how the math
money makes the ocean rise.
But that problem may
have just been solved.
- [Reporter] Ethereum pulls off the Merge.
- Ethereum just got revamped.
- The second largest blockchain,
Ethereum which is home
to the cryptocurrency
Ether has just completely
changed the way that it does
the whole crypto electricity
math verification thing.
This isn't just some
like changing the code
and hitting update.
This verification process
that they change is
like the beating heart of the blockchain.
Switching it out for something new is
like switching out the engine of a car
while it's hurling down the
road at like 120 miles an hour.
Insanely difficult to do.
So insanely difficult to do
that nobody else has ever dared
to try it.
But Ethereum they were like,
"It's worth it for the planet."
So they start working
on this transition for years and years.
They're tinkering away.
They're testing it,
they're perfecting it until
September 15th, 2022 when they finally
flipped the switch and.
(power draining)
So what happened?
Did it all crash and burn and die
and the Ethereum blockchain is no more?
Did the car go hurtling off
the highway without an engine?
(dramatic music)
No, actually it went off without a hitch.
Which again for me, I'm just
like, "Cool, good job guys."
But the thing that blew my mind is this.
Look at this graph.
I mean, look at this graph.
This is the energy consumption
of the Ethereum blockchain.
Look at that drop off.
We're talking about a 99.5%
drop in power consumption
for this blockchain.
I mean, to give you some context here
before this transition,
which they called The Merge
the Ethereum blockchain was
consuming the same amount
of electricity as the country of Chile.
It's as if a major developed
country was suddenly taken
off the planet's energy bill.
The CEO of the Ethereum
blockchain, claimed that this one
software update has reduced global power
consumption by 0.2%.
Which is just like (imitates explosion).
They did this by changing
from the math puzzle race
the proof of work race
which they had to do to verify
all all their transactions
to a totally different
system called proof of stake.
So now instead of having a bunch
of computers around the
world racing each other
all sucking up energy
to do this big math race
now every computer that wants
to verify a block has to put
in a stake, a small amount
of cryptocurrency that then puts you
in the running to verify a block.
Sort of like buying a lottery ticket.
- If you wanna win the lottery
you have to make the
money to buy a ticket.
- Then through a very complex process
that I will not go into here,
a single random computer is
picked to verify that block
and take home that
sweet, sweet commission.
So no more of these
big crypto farms racing
against each other to see
who can get there first
contributing the most processing power.
Instead, it's just one computer
doing the very light lifting
of verifying a block, because
again, it was the racing
all of these machines working
simultaneously that used
up the power, not the
verification process itself.
So there you have it.
The cryptoverse was saved.
The power hungry computers
were turned offline.
- Shut it down.
- And the world energy
consumption plummeted all
over the globe.
The ice caps stopped melting
and the pollution was reduced
to their lowest levels in 40 years.
(fist knocking)
- Actually, that's not
what happened at all
and the cryptoverse is far from saved.
- Skeptic Johnny, I didn't
know you were gonna be here.
I thought you moved to Tampa.
- I heard you were making another video
so I thought I'd stop by.
Can I come in?
- I guess?
- Okay, good to be back.
(doorbell ringing)
- Crypto Johnny.
- Hey, I heard you guys were talking
about crypto and I'm here to tell you
that the crypto verse
might not be totally saved
but this is a huge step
in the right direction.
I'm coming in.
- Oh gosh, why do crypto
people always have
to be so polarized?
Can't we just stay curious
about this new technology
and just see what happens?
- No.
- Okay, fine.
Let's do this again.
Can I at least get some Doritos?
(bag crinkling)
Okay.
Oh, I thought the video was over.
Well then, let's do this.
Skeptic Johnny, you start.
I honestly wanna hear
what you have to say.
I thought that The Merge
and this huge proof
of stake thing was like
a huge win for crypto.
So what's your rebuttal?
- No, I mean, you're totally right.
Having Ethereum switch to
proof of stake was a huge deal.
Is a huge deal.
A completely like that graph
that you showed earlier.
Super impressive.
- Thank you, didn't realize
this was gonna be so amicable.
- But let's be clear
that this is just one of a
million problems facing crypto.
The crypto space is still rife
with scams and volatility.
The real reason your
little project hasn't taken
off yet is because regular
people are way too afraid
of losing their money
with a cryptocurrency
that can be worth $65,000 one month
and then a couple months
later worth $35,000.
- Word.
- Wait, what?
- No, that happened to me.
- What, you invested?
- After the last video when
this guy gave his big
crypto sermon I was kind
of convinced and things were going well
and so I went and I bought
like a thousand bucks worth
of crypto and now it's worth like 300.
- Yeah, case in point,
you and like everyone else
who dabbled in crypto.
- You'll make it all back.
You just need to hold.
- Okay, but even if he does make it back
the volatility of crypto isn't
actually its biggest problem.
- If it's not the environment
and it's not the volatility
which I'm concerned
about what is it?
- This ought to be good.
- It turns out that crypto's
biggest problem is that guy.
- Hey, how's it going guys?
- Oh God, not this guy.
- Wait, there's more of you?
What is this?
I don't do this.
Who the hell is this guy?
- That is Johnny Law and he is hard
at work thinking about
how to regulate crypto.
The real existential threat
to crypto right now is not volatility
or the environment or
the lack of adoption.
It is regulators.
♪ Regulators mount up ♪
No one's gonna get that reference
unless they had an older brother who was
into hip hop in the nineties.
- Hey, my brother had that album too.
Love Nate Dog.
- Before you go into the SEC.
- Wait, hold on.
Let me just finish this
thought about the government
and regulators before you
can have your rebuttal.
The fact is we did see some
governments embrace crypto.
Like the government
of El Salvador who like
made it legal tender.
At that same time
other governments were
showing what it looks
like when you regulate crypto.
In China, they've outright banned crypto.
You're not allowed to conduct any kind
of transactions in or
outside of the country
and you're not even allowed to mine it.
Totally banned.
- Yeah, that's cool but
China still accounts
for the second most mining
activity in the world.
It's almost as if, I don't know
the rise of the crypto
verse is inevitable, okay.
Governments be damned.
- You may actually get a
front row seat to see how
unstoppable the crypto verse is
because the United States may be next.
- No, no, you're getting it all wrong.
Me and the USA, we're chill.
We love crypto in the U.S.
It's all about freedom.
It's all about doing what you love, okay.
Me and Matt Damon we're like best friends.
- Fortune favors the brave.
- Yeah, but Matt Damon
doesn't pass regulations
in the United States.
The SEC does.
- Mm, wait, wait, I know that one.
SEC, Security and Exchange
Commission, right?
- Yes, great work.
Real Johnny's real smart.
(chips crunching)
But yes, that is correct.
The SEC is a thing
in the United States that is
meant to protect investors.
- You just don't get it.
- I mean, look at this
article that I have here
from the head of the SEC that wrote it
in the Wall Street Journal.
- Wait, did you actually
print off that paper?
- Yes, I printed it out.
It helps me read it.
I'm dyslexic.
Do you have an issue with that?
- I didn't say that.
- Dude, I'm dyslexic too
and I love printing things.
Especially in big font.
- Thank you.
Anyway, head of the SEC writing
in the Wall Street Journal.
Guess how many times he
mentions the environment?
I mean, here you look at it.
- Geez.
- Did that article mention anything
about the environmental
concerns of crypto?
- Hold on, I'm checking.
- Here, I'll just tell you, it doesn't.
The SEC doesn't care
about the environment.
That's the EPA.
The SEC cares about one thing.
Protecting Americans from being scammed.
So yeah, it is amazing that
the Ethereum blockchain
was able to get off of its
insane energy consumption.
That is a great step, but the
crypto verse is still riddled
with the same old
problems it's always had.
The problems that the SEC is
rearing to sort out with a bit
of good old regulation.
♪ Regulators ♪
- Calls are being renewed
for oversight and
legislation from Congress.
- But wait, they're not gonna
like ban crypto in the U.S.?
Like this isn't China, right?
- Ha, yes, thank you.
This is all overblown.
- I mean, yeah, they're not
gonna ban it completely.
You're totally right.
But they could reclassify crypto
as a security instead of a commodity.
Right Johnny Law?
- I mean, yeah, theoretically they could.
- Yeah, I'm gonna be honest.
I don't know what that means.
- Basically what this means
is that crypto would now
be registered with the SEC.
Like Ethereum would have to register Ether
and all other applications
with the government.
- Yeah, that doesn't sound great
for the whole untraceable, unregulated
crypto utopia philosophy.
- No, it doesn't.
- Okay, okay.
You've talked with all your
nerdy regulation stuff.
This is 100% speculation.
There's no proof that they're
actually gonna do this.
And besides, even if they do a regulated
but still decentralized
monetary system is a lot better
than a regulated centralized one
like the one that we have with banks.
- I am so glad you brought that up.
- Oh, this is getting good.
- So let's talk about decentralization.
It's one of the main pillars
of the whole crypto project, right?
- Yeah, obviously.
- Great, then you'll be interested to know
that since they did this big Merge,
this big flip to proof of stake
almost half of all
transactions now happening on
the Ethereum blockchain are
taking place from two addresses.
Only two, two addresses.
So much for decentralized.
- Yeah, but the fact -
- Oh wait, I'm not done yet.
One sec.
I just need to say one more thing
which is all of those
farms that I'm telling you
about that are now like
defunct and obsolete.
Do you really think those
people are just gonna
like pack up and go home and be like,
"Well, we have no use
for our like hundreds
"of expensive computers and
mining farms in Iceland?"
No, they're just gonna
switch to another blockchain
that can use their computers
to do the same old thing
that they've been doing forever,
which is mining blockchain
through proof of work.
That energy consumption
isn't disappearing.
It's just being transferred.
- Holy shit.
Sorry, sorry, but a couple
weeks ago I was in Switzerland.
- Is there ever gonna be a video
where you don't mention Switzerland?
- Seriously, dude?
- No, of course not.
But anyway, when I was in that
Swiss bunker, which was right
around the time that this
Merge was happening, it was
like the end of September,
they told me that they
were shutting down their mining operation
for a little bit.
- [Crypto Miner] Just last week.
It says it's not making money right now.
So I'll take a break.
- [Johnny] Yeah.
- And it must have been
because of the Merge.
- Cool and their next step
was to just like destroy all
of those really expensive computers
and revamp the bunker
to be some hip Airbnb?
Is that what their plan was?
- I mean, no, they're
probably just looking
for like other blockchains
to like use all their hardware on.
- Yeah, exactly.
It was sort of a rhetorical thing.
I didn't know you were gonna actually try
to answer the question.
That was kind of embarrassing.
- Okay, I'm gonna cut you off there
because it's my turn to speak, okay.
You've been just
blabbering this whole time.
So yes, a lot of these miners are moving
to other blockchains to
use their big mining farms
but this is just the beginning.
This is early days.
Do you realize all
technologies start out clunky?
You wanna hear my prediction?
The biggest effect isn't
the big graph that goes
down to zero of all of
its energy consumption.
It's how it's gonna
inspire other blockchains
to do the same thing.
To adopt proof of stake.
Like imagine if the Bitcoin blockchain
adopted proof of stake.
It would change the world.
It would literally change the world.
- But that's never gonna happen.
Bitcoin has zero plans to switch
to proof of stake or any
other way of verifying.
And unlike Ethereum, which
is run like a business.
They have a CEO that can
actually make these decisions
top down Bitcoin is this
super decentralized project.
You would need 51%
of the users to all agree to
switch something this big.
It's not gonna happen anytime soon.
- But they might not have a choice.
If the rest
of this master plan that
Ethereum has goes as smoothly
as the Merge, then it's gonna be more
of a case of adapt or die.
- Wait a plan, what are you talking?
- Oh, you haven't heard?
The Merge is just the beginning.
Oh man, buckle up for this one.
After the Merge, we have the Surge
then the Verge, then the
Purge, then the Splurge.
- Really, the Splurge?
Why do these tech companies
always have to come
up with these cutesy (beep) naming things?
- The Surge is just the next
part of the master plan.
It involves massively scaling
up the Ethereum blockchain
which is way easier to do now
that we have proof of stake verification.
Okay, so you're probably
asking what would this scaling
up even do?
- I actually didn't ask.
- It would mean instead
of the Ethereum blockchain
being able to perform
like 20 transactions per second,
it would be able to perform
over a hundred thousand
transactions in a second.
Guys, this is huge.
Don't even get me started on the Verge.
- Yada, yada, yada.
I feel like this is just another set
of empty words to get people excited
so they invest in the math
money project that you're doing.
Every time we talk about crypto, it seems
like it always goes to this.
Some like life changing,
world changing technology
that's just right around the
corner if we all just believe.
It just feels like yet another stop
along the crypto hype train
and I'm not here for it.
- Okay, okay.
I think I'm gonna call it there guys.
- But Johnny, I wanted
to talk about the Verge.
- Zip it Crypto Johnny.
I'm shutting it down, okay?
We've had enough.
You can talk about the
Verge when inevitably
I make another one of these
videos in like six months.
'Cause apparently that's what I do now.
For now, let me just say this.
The Merge was indeed an
incredible technical feat.
It was a huge boon for the environment.
I mean, that graph is insane.
This is gonna be a great thing
for the planet no matter what
but will it save the cryptoverse alone?
Probably not.
There are way more trials
and tribulations to overcome.
This technology is barely a decade old.
We don't have to have these
strong opinions on either side.
The reality is none of us
know what's gonna happen next.
So why don't we all just
agree to sit back, relax
and see what happens next.
- Nope, not gonna happen.
- He says the same thing every time.
"Let's all hold hands and be friends."
No.
- Okay, I'd give up.
- Whatever, do you guys wanna
go get beer or something?
- I've actually been super
into hard kombucha lately.
- Of course you have.
- Yeah, I actually know a
great place down the road.
Let's go.
- Okay, let's go.
- Let's do it.
(upbeat music)